the first reports were dire with
emergency services saying more than 200
miners could be trapped underground in
an illegal abandoned gold shaft near
Johannesburg the rescue services had
audio contact with a small group of
around 30 who claimed there were many
more like them in another section of the
mine underneath them cranes and other
equipment were brought in to try to
leave a boulders out which were blocking
the exit water was lowered down and then
six hours after the emergency operation
started slowly one by one looking dazed
and dusty the miners climbed out they
told their rescuers they'd been attacked
by a rival group of illegal workers who
deliberately thrown concrete blocks in
the shaft to track them underground
but after eleven of them had surfaced
apparently none the worse for wear they
were immediately arrested and suddenly
the operation ground to a halt if there
are any others down there they appear to
have decided to take their chances
underground rather than face the law
this is an illegal operation obviously
people are it was going to happen to
them when they come out when they come
out but we have the eleven that came out
and well we think we have done enough we
will leave the place open if they want
to come out they will come out you do
not know whether they still more because
when we try to call there was no more
answers and then we suppose that 11
people that we had how discouraged the
community is not to engage in this type
of activity that is very dangerous for
themselves and for those that are
supposed to perform rescue as they are a
scrappy homemade rope ladder seems to
have been how they got down in the first
place a small security presence will
remain just in case others surface the
rescue services and the authorities will
be very much hoping that this whole
operation acts as some sort of deterrent
to any other people who are thinking
about doing illegal mining the risks are
so high and it is so dangerous these
people had an incredible escape
the reality is though it probably won't
deter others Alex Crawford Sky News in
Johannesburg